[Music]
let's go to chris down the road in
memphis tennessee what's up chris
hey what's up just rocking on dude what
are you doing
i am just
calling him
good job man what's up
so i'm having a problem with
communication with my wife
and not in the way of being able to
express our needs with each other and
being able to fulfill them
but in the way of just having a friendly
conversation be able to hold
conversation and just having something
to talk about like if i had a friend
come into my car and we're driving 30
minutes down the road like we'll talk
all the way until we get to destination
b but
i feel like a lot of times with my wife
i don't know if there's just nothing to
talk about or i have just so much stuff
running through my brain that work or
it's just it's starting to cause a
problem with connection
why why have you put that expectation
that you have to talk everywhere you go
no it's not i'm not saying that
at all the time we need to talk but it
has become a problem to where
there's just not enough talking like
we're just sitting too much or i'm not
communicating with her enough just being
a friend to her hmm
why are you choosing that
i don't know i don't know if it's
if it's just my mind is consumed with
work or
yeah like i feel like there's nothing to
talk about or i don't know
no it's not one of those two things
because both of those are choices
so i'm not looking for the question
beneath that question because everybody
i know works really hard
and they could if they wanted to let
their minds be consumed to work all the
time and there's a few days
out of a month that my brain is super
consumed with work
um and that's just part of being a human
and being alive
but there are days when i can choose i'm
just gonna keep thinking about where
keeping my work or i'm gonna
choose to think about and talk about my
wife talk to her about our home about
our family life and stuff like that
um
my wife and i here's what i'm struggling
my wife and i dude have
like she likes singer-songwriters man
and i do too but i really like old punk
rock and i like to go to metal shows and
she would prefer to go to a theater
and
she writes like
historical fiction man and i
you know
i can't think of two people who i know
who have more different things that they
care about and love in the world than me
and my wife
and there's never something there's we
always have things to talk about and i'm
not afraid of two hours of silence when
we're driving on a trip somewhere that's
some great time too just to sit in my
head so
i don't put i don't put this weight on
the other side of the scale and that's
what i'm getting at is
either a there are things you want to
talk about that you're afraid to bring
up with her or that you can't bring up
with her because it's not safe to
there's something you want to tell her
and you don't want to do it
or b you're just kind of a jerk and
you're just staying in your own head
you're kind of you're starving your wife
of your relationship
am i missing something
you know i would say
um a lot of times i
might not bring up stuff because
like if it has to do with work or
whatever i mean we own a couple
companies and
sometimes i don't want to bring up
certain situations with her because
she might want to do something a
different way
and i i disagree with it and it's it's
just kind of getting past the argument
or
sometimes just best to
not tell her about it
um
so let me let me let me let me give you
a line i want you to tattoo this on your
heart okay
conflict delayed is conflict amplified
a hundred percent of the time
you've now started like lying to your
wife by omission
because it's just easier
instead of having a harder conversation
which which is should we be in business
together or is it wise for us to run
businesses together and be married
because it looks like we're on a
collision course here
well it's not that it's not that she
runs it with me it's just
she doesn't run it at all um it's just
if i were to come and bring a situation
to her and i tell her how i handled it
then she would give her
input that
a lot of times it's not a um
constructive criticism it's more of just
a criticism sure that's fair so are you
more than work
a lot of times i'm not but i try to be i
mean i i definitely try to be
so
give me like a solid question
here's what it feels like it feels like
you are
um
again dude lean in and tell me i'm wrong
okay tell me i'm wrong on this
it feels like you're in a pool
and the water's like up to your waist
and you are just splashing around
and you're like ah i can't get out of
the water it's wet in here
and then we're all sitting on the side
like we'll just get out of the pool
you're like i can't
like i'll just get a pool man like
i i can't i don't i don't know where
i don't know what you're struggling with
there's something beneath this that
you're that you're not telling me what
is it
i guess
i would say
um
what is it how do i how do i bring my
wife into my work life
without
even though it's not her ambition or her
wants or her needs to be a part of it
really in the way that i want her to be
um there it is there it is right there
yeah
she doesn't care about your job she
cares about her you
should give a crap about your business
intricacies and who did what and the
plumbing at this facility is busted and
i can't believe in the profits over she
didn't care any of that she cares about
chris
right and because this means so much to
you like you're like a favorite band
when you were in high school
you've said
here's a rule i made dude if you didn't
like seinfeld i knew we weren't going to
be friends i used to ask that question
like in the first time i the first
conversation i met people hey do you
like seinfeld and they'd be like nah and
i you just know we're not gonna be
friends
i have one friend in my life who doesn't
like seinfeld to this day and that's my
wife
of 20 years
but you've created a world where if you
don't like this then we're probably not
gonna that's like why have you boxed
yourself in that way she didn't care
about your job so what
like what do you want well i just i just
feel that
i wish
i thought going into marriage i thought
we would be able to um go forward
together and build something together
and even if she's on the sideline of not
running it but at least be like
i guess more of a cheerleader or more of
i don't a i guess have interest i i okay
can i can i poke it what i think it is
absolutely how long have you been
married
coming up on three years okay all right
perfect so first thing you mentioned is
beautiful and this is your starting
point with your wife
you had a picture of what marriage was
going to be and that was going to be you
were going to be busting it real hard
crush like you were going to be working
really hard in business you're going to
do good
and she was going to be super she's
going to be right there by your side
cheering you on
and now you're three years in and you're
realizing i'm busting it really hard and
my wife could care less what my job is
and i try to bring her in and then it
ends up she gives me some bad advice
like why don't you just fire him he's
like i can't just fight and now we're in
a thing right
yeah it took me 16 years 15 years
trying to think when our last big
mess was me and my wife
let me say 15 years
for me to tell my wife
i've been working for 15 years for
you to say
um
three or four but
four magic words
i'm proud of you
and as a texas male it was really hard
for me to say those words out loud i
felt ashamed i felt small i felt
embarrassed i just wanted my wife to say
i'm really proud of you i see how hard
you're working for the family i see how
hard you're working the lives of other
people etc etc
and until i said those words out loud
she didn't get it because she thought
our fights were when i was coaching like
i would just tell her all the track
times she's like i don't care and when i
was working higher ed i was telling
about all the budget numbers and the
suicides and that i just don't i mean i
don't care about that i don't like i
don't i mean it's not a thing if i
wanted to do if i was interested in that
i would have done those jobs too and i
don't i don't care about them
and i took that to me and she didn't
care about me
when i came to find out is she loved me
deeply
i just wanted her to be proud of me
and when i said that she broke down i
broke down and she said man i sure would
have shoe told me that 15 years ago
because i'm so proud of you i can't
breathe right so it was giving her
language that i needed it was me
um doing the brave courageous probably
most manly thing i could do which is say
here's what i need
that makes sense
and i don't know that you need somebody
that is walking alongside you just pat
you on the back and saying tell you how
great and smart and beautiful you are
and how
care about your business as much as you
want her to acknowledge how hard you
work in and the contribution you're
making to your home is that fair
there so i'd start there with a
conversation and dude the pictures you
had coming into marriage everyone it
throws everyone off so you're not in a
bad spot
i just had to quit talking to my wife
about uh
track times i had to quit talking about
higher ed issues and talk to her about
other things way to develop other things
to talk about
we had to create shared experiences so
we would have things to talk about
and sometimes she would just like
take one for the team and listen to me
talk about work and vice versa i didn't
really understand we're talking about
with k-12 education whatever but i
listened i got there see what i'm saying
it's both in it's gonna take
is is there a deeper tension here
i would say that
um
it's hard to if she if she doesn't want
to be involved and she doesn't you know
like you said that she didn't care about
the business she cares about me
it's hard to want to grow or i want to
grow and continue working and to
continue building
but if she
doesn't want me to it's hard on me to
like
give up my dreams or wants
if
it's not ours
um
you know it's almost as if i'm trying to
force it to be ours yeah
and
i think that's like devastating to me
because it's all i've really ever wanted
in my entire life
was what was what
just
building a business and growing a
business and
so she told you i don't want you growing
a business
growing it more than what we have it's
um
normally that conversation is i miss my
husband
like yeah right that's exactly what it
is and i think i've told this on the
podcast if i haven't shame on me
it was this year that my wife held my
face and said john we have enough stop
i need you and i'm thinking yeah but i
need more of this i need to write
another book and i got to get this thing
out and i got to get i'm going on a tour
i've got to go hit the road
and she said we have enough
and i had to drop my shoulders and ask
myself am i chasing ambition am i
chasing ego or am i trying to give my
family a better shot
yeah and that was me looking in the
mirror had nothing to do with my wife
in fact she was the one that just called
it out said from this point forward any
more hours you work anymore money you
make isn't for us it's to feed your own
whatever you're trying to solve
and that was a hard thing for me to hear
but she was right
and by the way it's not mutually
exclusive
what i've done now is i've haven't
really throttled back that much but i
have had to speak my needs and be more
firm at work and set up boundaries at
work and i've been much more clear at
home
little things like putting my phone down
leaving my social media phone here at
work doing some things that just create
some space at home so that when i'm
there i'm fully there and i'm not
thinking about the business all day as a
young business owner
building a business can take your life
over and it can take your soul over and
i've done the research and sat with
folks who have done that for 50 years
and they're 60 and they're and they
think
oh i gave
up everything i have no memories i've
got no kids or i've got two kids that
don't like me i've got a big bank
account and i've got nothing
and so the work is not
giving up one or the other don't back
yourself into a corner that way
but it's saying what does growing the
business look like and what does
really swan diving um into the
relationship with my wife look like
those aren't mutually exclusive they're
gonna come they're gonna they're gonna
be a totter it's gonna be a balance and
she's dealing with with that picture
from the other side too right she had a
picture of a marriage where at five
o'clock every day chris would come home
and we would talk and laugh and
and her picture's gonna be different too
that's why where you start is y'all go
on a retreat together you've heard me
say this a million times
go on a retreat together and say hey
we're three years in
we have different pictures
let's create a unified single picture
and let's work towards it together and
that's going to be you giving up some
stuff and her giving up some stuff and
both of you getting some great things
together and then we're off to the races
do you see it what a different view that
is
yeah
can you do do you think you can do that
or you think your wife is saying i want
you to quit this business and go do
something else
no she doesn't want me to quit or
anything but it's just
she wants the growth to stop but
what is the growth costing her
um
it costs her the
i guess mental stress on me when i come
home
okay um you hear what that means you are
not telling you're not hearing her words
correctly
her words are not telling you to stop
working on the business even though
that's what she said
her words are i'm watching the man i
love die in front of me and call it his
dream
i'm watching the man i love the man i
stood before our friends and family and
said i'm all in forever i'm watching him
slowly drown in front of me and say look
how happy i am
that's what she's saying chris
so how do i get past my
my
desires my
it's not both and
grow the business and decide that next
year you're going to make 30 000 fewer
dollars and you're going to hire an
assistant that's gonna take care of x
and y and z
decide next year you're gonna make 65
000 less dollars and hire a senior
manager that's going to run the ship for
you
put on an all an on-call staff so that
at five o'clock only three people call
you and that's if something is on fire
somebody's dead
everything else can work till tomorrow
this is about um a
young business owner running a new
business trying to grow it and having no
boundaries
and what you're gonna find is two
important cool things number one
this thing will keep going without you
hovering and breathing over it every
second and number two when you have time
to think and time to
have great wild evenings with your wife
and y'all go do fun stuff and like each
other and have fun and you
develop that relationship you're gonna
be a thousand times better back on the
ball field
and i know that it sounds like yo dude
whatever i'm i live it dude i'm doing it
right now i promise you
i think it starts with this i think it
starts with you taking your wife out and
saying over the last three years i have
been cheating on you with my business
and
i have told you you're my priority but
my behavior is a language and what i've
demonstrated to you is the most
important thing in my life is building
this business
and i've got my pro priorities backwards
my most important priority in my life is
my wife
it's our family it's what we're doing
together
and i am really passionate about this
business
and i will give it all up if that's what
it takes but i don't think that's what
it takes can you see some things in me
that you've seen shift and change over
the last few years
that i can
work to manage around as this business
grows
things like time things like a personal
assistant things like somebody checking
email things like a commitment to it six
o'clock when you get home the phones are
all off and i'm gonna outsource that
whatever those things are on the
weekends i do not take work calls unless
there is somebody dead
or dying
right i'm going to create some really
strong boundaries
your wife's telling you that she loves
you and she misses you and she doesn't
want to watch you die right in front of
her
she's not telling you to quit your
business she's just watching the
business kill you
and please my brother
don't don't see this as the end of times
it's not your business or your wife you
can absolutely do both together it's
going to be
coming up with boundaries and working
together
holler at me let me know how that dinner
goes i'd love to hear about it